before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
series 11 was a bit of a stumble can
this one at least start out better
foreign
[Music]
folks my take two Doctor Who reviews
continue and I am going right in to
series 12 and I am already on record as
thinking series 12 is a significant
improvement over series 11 and I
remember it being that way pretty much
right from the off and having now
re-watched spyfall part one
yeah yeah I still feel that we'll see if
that feeling holds as I work through the
series but yeah this is definitely
starting on stronger more self-assured
footing than series 11 did now part of
that is still from decisions that make
me go hmm a little bit because a lot of
it feels very reactive there's a ton of
stuff that wasn't done in series 11 that
was immediately brought back not that I
think the Doctor Who shouldn't have
brought things like cold opens
two-parters classic villains Etc back
into the franchise and something other
than the New Year's special but at the
same time throwing them all back in
immediately after series 11 which
ditched pretty much all of those again
the special accepted at least when it
came to the classic villains but
throwing it back in all at once it it
just feels like they're scrambling to
try and make good on mistakes which on
the one hand does show that they are
trying to learn and improve on on the
other hand it feels a little bit
desperate that said it is still starting
out way way better so spyfall starts
with the deaths of various spies
actually the whole front end of this is
fairly committed to the Espionage bit
and it kind of keeps the vibe going for
a while I would say up until the last 10
minutes or so but I was kind of
surprised I don't think I've remembered
how much the uh the James Bond and spy
movie thread kind of ran through this in
a lot of ways like right from the
beginning it's a very spy movie opening
uh in general you know with a little bit
of a Sci-Fi news going on but then we
have you know the briefing with uh the
equivalent of M in C with Stephen Frye
and we've got let's investigate this
villain let's go consult uh an expert
let's crash a party you know we have the
chase it's it's very very spy movie I
think my memory of this had kind of
faded largely into a focus on on Sasha
Dewan and I kind of Forgotten uh how
much this is just embracing the vibe
it's going for
which is good I don't think Doctor Who
should be spy movie-esque on a regular
basis but if it's going to be that
this is a pretty decent version of it I
also feel like most of the actors have
settled into their roles a bit The
Companions especially again I don't
think the companion performances were
bad in series 11 and act and actually I
saw more in there that became things
that were picked up later I've seen a
lot of complaints of of sort of
inconsistencies and the characterization
of the companions like the thing about
Ryan's dyspraxia and how inconsistently
that is applied is absolutely valid but
honestly there were a lot of more things
in series 11 that I picked up I'm like
oh that is a thing with them that they
stick with but at the same time just as
a dynamic they feel more settled and
it's more fun that way also speaking of
things that that get established in a
matter later I did take a a quick extra
look uh Ryan's friend who's going to
come up again later in the series and
can you hear me does appear in this when
I and when I saw Ryan talking with his
friends and playing basketball I was
like wait is that him and then I checked
I'm like yeah it is
good good job I don't especially care
for the time that is spent you know
showing how the companions are making
excuses to go and travel with a doctor
we're like I know the Tardis is
unreliable but shouldn't we be able to
count at least a little bit on the
Tardis bringing the back around the same
time that they left I mean maybe not in
this particular instance since it is an
Earthbound story but in general like
should they be doing this kind of prep
should this be a regular thing where
they just kind of vanish off the face of
the Earth for a while and their friends
are like what are you even up to I mean
like I suppose again given how
inconsistent the Tardis has been about
being able to return to uh precise
points in time uh with any reliability
that maybe this just is a better way for
them to do it and to prepare for it but
at the same time I'm like I don't know I
don't think I needed this now let's talk
about Stephen Fry real quick he's a real
good stand-in for your m style character
if you watch James Bond movies uh I
don't love the whole the doctors and
thing just less it's less that I don't
like the beat I think the beat is fine I
think it's just played in the most
generic on the nose way that it could
possibly be I think that's a writing
issue not necessarily A Stephen Fry
issue so I don't love that moment but
overall he brings a good sense of
authority and also a good sense of
desperation is too strong a word a good
sense of need like when he's saying to
the doctor we need your help like I
believe him I believe him so that works
I kind of like the way the creatures are
done they are they're weird and they're
kind of tricky to wrap your head around
because they're either kind of have the
impression of the world kind of wrapped
around them or they are almost
blindingly bright and those are nice
off-putting designs and also
surprisingly simple but yeah quite
effective so I dig them the whole thing
with Yaz and Ryan going to interview the
CEO whose name has now already left my
head uh the CEO of Vore
um
Chris Mr chimnall
have somebody on your team Google the
terms you intend to use granted it's not
spelled the same way but is pronounced
the same way if you as an audience if
you don't know what vorys don't Google
it
but like it's well known enough
that
these characters really really really
should not have been saying it as often
as they do it's off-putting for anyone
with any internet literacy who knows
what that term means and if it's
intentional it's a bad call because it's
distracting so yeah that's a side note
though anyways the whole uh
investigative journalist thing the cover
for Yaz and Ryan to go in and talk to
this guy I think he's handled pretty
well because first of all that uh format
well it fits the spy movie stuff the
coming up with a fake reason to get in
there and and just talk and try and suss
out your villain but also in addition to
that it's a decent vehicle for some of
the exposition that we're gonna get
about him uh both in terms of his
history and as a character because we
get to see what a callous unfeeling ass
he is and through the lens of these
questions that Yaz is asking him that's
a pretty good vehicle for some
Exposition is it a seamless one well no
I can tell it's a vehicle for exposition
but it's one that makes sense it makes
sense that these questions are sort of
set up answer here's the information
because that's what an interview is so
if you're gonna put this information in
there in a in some way that is
straightforward this works and it's
smooth and it doesn't bug me I also
gotta love that even under cover Yaz
can't stop herself from kind of taking a
shot at this guy this information
online abuse cyber bullying all of which
you've been accused of ignoring haven't
you
props tour it it it's one of the other
traits of Yaz that I I wish more had
been done with but it is a consistency
she she gets uppity when she feels like
something is wrong that is being ignored
so it's a good moment again I kind of
wish as a character trait it had built
up into more but it still works here but
ultimately I think the thing to talk the
most about is the introduction of Sasha
Dewan as the master so there's a few
things here I actually when I was
rewatching I remember thinking how long
has he been pretending to be oh like
really except that later when it gets
revealed he's sort of just flat out like
when the doctor goes but I met oh and
he's like I know so it's it's like this
it's just in the performance it's like
the submission that he would do so far
out of his way just to mess with the
doctor better like there was no reason
for him to for him to set himself up at
MI6 the way he did for as long as he did
except to mess with the doctor but you
can tell he takes such Glee in that I
immediately buy oh
yeah he would go through all this
trouble just to mess with you okay okay
it's also really interesting to re-watch
knowing what the reveal is going to be
because when he is being oh first of all
the character is quite endearing and
nicely done so it's a decently fleshed
out character that I found myself liking
even before the reveal and going back
and re-watching it knowing what's coming
there's lots of little moments little
smirk Smiles little laughs that when you
watch it the first time play is a kind
of social awkwardness like he just
doesn't really know how to how to
interact around people he kind of laughs
at inappropriate times sometimes he gets
these little fleeting smiles and then he
pulls it back together I think because
he's trying to not be off-putting but
then re-watching it knowing who he is
and going oh this is where he's almost
breaking character because he's so
excited
about what he's going to put the doctor
through
that's that's actually a lot of fun
because the thing is I have rewatched
very little of the Jody Whitaker
Christian malaria so so even the stuff
that I liked likes by Fall I hadn't gone
back and re-watched since it initially
aired and so I'm kind of spotting those
things that had I rewatched it
previously I would have already known
but now I was like oh
oh and that's a lot of fun too and he's
just he's got you know here's the thing
about Sasha the one's master
he feels like
a refinement and a distillation of what
John Sim did in a way that actually
works for me because I've complained
about John Sim at least uh when he first
shows up in series three as being kind
of Saturday morning cartoonish he is
just so over the top he's so Manic and
honestly manic's a good word for Dewan
as well but it doesn't feel like he's
bouncing off the walls it feels like he
just has all this energy that he is just
trying to contain and focus and that is
a general impression that is similar to
sim but
it results in a very different overall
feel this feels more like someone who is
struggling to keep himself directed and
focused as much as he can on this when
part of him kind of wants to wander off
and do something else possibly or like
there's just so much energy to that
focusing on one thing is almost kind of
difficult for him whereas Johnson was
just kind of bouncing off the wall
because he was bouncing off the wall
um so I I prefer this and he's got some
great just intimidating looks and
moments and laughs and I really enjoy
his master again I going down the line
kind of wish more had come of it but
it's a good intro it's a good intro it's
a good moment it's a good performance
yeah I like him in this a lot some other
things I like I really like the sheer
alienness of the place where initially
yazzy gets sent and then later the
doctor ends up at the end of the episode
I like when the doctor confronts the CEO
at CEO's own party she gets right in his
face and tells him flat out yeah I know
this is what you're doing
because like
why why waste the time pretending
otherwise like I know what's up you
might as well know I know what's up
so let's just cut the crap
I dig it I like it and overall I do like
this it's a really strong first part and
there's a lot of little Intrigue from
the ideas of what are these creatures
doing what are they trying to accomplish
why is this guy's DNA only 93 human
that's like a real tantalizing number so
it's not like oh he's an alien it's like
well now he's mostly human but wait what
like that's a nice thread it just does a
really good job at pulling together its
characters its elements the vibe it's
going for
and it all hangs together really well in
this first part
I don't know how well I remember it
paying off in the second part I don't
remember disliking part two
but my gut tells me part one's the
stronger of these
well I'll find out next week I suppose
uh but for right now look spyfall is a
good start to this and I do think it is
broadly speaking a good episode
so what are your thoughts on this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it patreon
is what pays the bills it is what allows
me to do this as my living but even if
you aren't able to do that like share
and subscribe help me out as well
and there's links in the description
various things you can do to assist me
merge other places you can follow me
Twitch I've got books for sale Dad don't
worry too much about it though
at the end of the day what I really want
you to remember
is you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
thank you
end credits that means I need to shout
out my top Patron supporters Robin Moore
zupin fulla Tarak the thing that goes
joint in the anime Oliver B Linda
Walters emu delki leotha Boyd Troy lowly
Becky Sparks bernabe likes the poodle
Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor Shea lugurley Brendan Larose and
TT
thank you so much for your support you
can get your name in the credits too by
checking out the rewards on the patreon
you only try deep my earring once this
time that's much better
[Music]